joe rogan's still holding pretty strong
we're now being told by the fouchies of
the world
and all of them that if you in any way
resist efforts to mandate the masks and
mandate the vaccine
you're a murderer you're a threat to
public health you're politicizing
everything
rogan's not hearing it
rogan is is holding a show at madison
square garden he's sold a zillion
tickets already and now in new york
they're mandating the vaccine just like
they are in parts of europe
and so rogan faces this pro is he going
to
force his
fans many of whom have bought tickets
already to get the vaccine or
is he going to fight back
here's rogan's take
if someone has a
you know
an ideological or a physiological reason
for not getting vaccinated i don't want
to force them to get vaccinated to see a
stupid comedy show and i've already sold
13 000 tickets and now they say that
everybody has to be vaccinated
and you know i want everybody to know
that
you know you can get your money back i'm
not i'm not an anti-vaxx person right in
fact i said i believe they're safe and i
encouraged many people to take them my
parents were vaccinated i just said i
don't think that if you're a young
healthy person that you need it their
argument was
you need it for other people so you
don't transmit the virus that makes more
sense so i'm a young but that's a
different argument
yeah and and by the way what joe is
leaving unsaid here at least in this
little clip is okay so now their
argument is you don't need it for
yourself because if you're vaccinated
you're totally fine and you know you're
not going to face serious consequences
of the virus and if you're unvaccinated
you're taking that risk but if you're
unvaccinated you're risking infecting
others
except that we are now told by the
studies by the science that the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated are
carrying similar viral loads that they
might not be as likely to face
hospitalization or death but they are as
likely to carry and transmit the virus
we'll get to more on that in just a
second but first i need to invite you
into my bed
helix sleep helix sleep has a quiz it
takes two minutes to complete it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you why would
you buy a mattress that were made for
someone else does that make sense you
could get one that's made for you that
makes a lot more sense to me with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way that you
sleep they've got soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
helix is terrific you don't need to take
my word for it helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq and wired magazine you go to
helixsleep.com
knowles right now take their two-minute
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life it ships for
free it's got a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free and then they'll pick it up if
you want them to but trust me you're not
going to need that helix is offering up
to 200 off right now all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com knowles that is
helixsleep.com
knowles for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
so then do you see the problem here for
the people saying you need to get faxed
for others
whether you're vast or unvaxed you may
very well carry the virus and transmit
it to others the thing that's going to
determine whether you go to the hot
whether anyone goes to the hospital or
dies according to the science according
to the experts according to the
politicians
is whether or not you have the vaccine
so it falls right back to this question
of personal choice
personal prudential judgment
what risk am i going to take as joe
rogan
correctly says
if you are a young person
you are at a very very low risk
of facing serious complications of the
virus if you're a morbidly obese 85 year
old
maybe you're at a higher risk okay maybe
you're gonna have a different
calculation
but if you're a young person the
arguments that the
the people who are mandating vaccines
are making don't make any sense they
don't make any sense at all and so rogan
hats off to him he's saying you know if
i don't i don't feel comfortable
mandating that my audience gets the
vaccine so you can have your money back
now eric clapton is going even further
than that clapton's saying he will not
play at venues because eric clapton had
the vaccine so he was open to it it's
not like he's totally anti-vaxxed he was
open to it he had a very negative
reaction we know the cdc and the fda
have told us that you can have negative
reactions to these vaccines there have
been to these vaccines there have been
multiple reported incidents of them and
clapton said yeah really paralyzed my
hands i couldn't play for a while so i'm
not playing
to houses that are mandating the backs
rogan is taking a sort of middle round
here and he's saying look i'll i'll play
i guess especially since we booked the
show before
the the city mandated this but i'm there
is no way i'm forcing my guys to get
this vaccine absolutely right
we are living in a world right now where
you can't trust the president of the
united states you can't trust the
military leadership they've all lost
their freaking minds you can't trust the
public health experts because they've
been wrong about a lot of stuff and in
some cases have lied to you you're
living in a world where joe rogan is a
much more credible person
than most of our
elected and appointed leaders
[Music]
[Music]
you